Armed with an abstract model of
a message-passing algorithm, what about
a programming model that implements it
so that we can write an actual program.
That's the topic of this lesson.
It's a particular library standard
called the message passing interface,
or MPI for short.
Now I've picked out a couple
of things for you to read so
that you can get familiar
with how MPI works.
The main things I want you
to keep an eye out for
are how to do hello world in MPI.
How to do asynchronous sends and
receives using the routines MPI I send,
I receive, wait, and wait all.
How to use the built in collective
operations like barriers, reductions,
scatters, gathers, all to alls.
And finally,
what the heck is a communicator?
MPI_COMM_WORLD, what is that?
Now, sometime after you're done,
I'm sure there will be
an assignment of some sort to give
you hands on experience with MPI.
So pay attention!